salud de derecho américa de france 24 y
con más romeros ahora vamos a hablar de
los fallecidos por la pandemia de kobe
19 en el mundo desde el inicio de esta
emergencia sanitaria mar porque se cree
que podría ser hasta 15 millones de
personas si buenos días raúl hoy vamos a
ir un poquito más detrás de estas cifras
generales ver qué nos cuentan y de qué
dolores también nos hablan las cifras
oficiales del recuento oficial está en
seis millones de doscientos mil
aproximadamente de fallecidos pero como
decía raúl las estimaciones de la
organización mundial de la salud elevan
esa cifra hasta 15 millones
aproximadamente vamos a poner estas
cifras en perspectiva también porque a
medida que los números van creciendo a
veces perdemos un poco de qué cantidades
estamos hablando para para parecernos
una idea a 6 millones aproximadamente la
población del salvador 15 millones es
aproximadamente si sumáramos la
población de costa rica- más la de
honduras pedimos disculpas a los
espectadores de centroamérica por estas
por usarlas en estas estadísticas tan
lúgubres pero básicamente nos podemos
hacer una idea de que en estos dos años
de pandemia ha muerto tanta gente como
la población de algunos de los países de
centroamérica que tenemos más cerca
también para ayudar a poner en
perspectiva las muertes por cáncer cada
año son de unos 10 millones vemos que en
el caso del cobat ambos quedarían por
debajo porque los 15 millones están
repartidos en dos años pero igual pues
nos habla de esta gran cantidad de
mortalidad y de vidas que se han perdido
por este virus marc hablemos entonces de
las muertes del cob y 19 las
desigualdades que hay en estas cifras no
porque no a todos nos ha afectado por
igual las muertes son definitivamente no
y a veces en estas grandes cifras parece
que todos hemos sufrido por igual que
las muertes al final la muerte es algo
que nos iguala a todos a que nos da los
mismos dolores y a pesar de que hay
parte del abierto en eso tenemos que
recordar que estas víctimas y por tanto
también esos duelos no se han repartido
de forma igualitaria en todo el mundo
vamos a de colombia por ejemplo que
tiene este sistema de estratos que nos
va a ejemplificar muy bien de qué
estamos hablando en el tema de las
desigualdades sociales en colombia hay
barrios que se reparten por pues por
estratos sociales no es indicador 100%
fiel pero nos puede dar una idea vemos
que el 87% total de las repartido entre
estrato 1 2 y 3 que son los estratos de
las clases medias y de las clases bajas
vemos que la proporción es radicalmente
distinta con los estratos 4 5 y 6 que
sería la mitad más bien estante de
colombia de este país latinoamericano
por qué pues porque estamos hablando al
final de gente que era trabajador
esencial durante las etapas más duras de
la cuarentena que no podían dejar de
salir a trabajar trabajadores informales
también y gente pues que tiene un peor
acceso a la salud y esto pues tiene
consecuencias como estamos viendo en
estas cifras consecuencias en lamentable
consecuencias que les han curado la vida
estas personas lamentablemente más que
otros factores de desigualdad han
influido unas muertes en la pandemia
vamos a hablar de las diferencias
también entre razas y etnias que también
han sido un gran factor en quiénes son
estos que han muerto durante estos estos
dos años de pandemia vamos a eeuu en
este caso una gráfica que hizo el 'new
york times' con fuentes de los cetes de
los centros de control de enfermedades
de estados unidos y vemos cómo se abre
otra brecha dolorosa las líneas
moradas son la población latina las
líneas rojas de la población afro la
línea en cambio de color azul es la
población blanca vemos que en todos los
rangos de edades ha afectado diferente
esta tasa de mortalidad pero es que
sobre todo en los rangos de edades
intermedios en los que todavía está la
población trabajadora porque pues porque
de nuevo las personas latinas las
personas afro de eeuu eran esas que
tenían unos trabajos pues que los ponían
también en mayor riesgo también
trabajadores de la salud como enfermeros
enfermeras que pues sabemos que
sufrieron más especialmente en esos
primeros meses de pandemia marc qué pasa
con las personas que sobreviven la
pérdida de sus seres queridos por
supuesto porque toda esta muerte también
tiene una dimensión emocional que no
podemos dejar de olvidar no podemos
dejar de lado también siguiendo en eeuu
donde pues muchos niños y muchos menores
de edad han perdido a sus padres
escuchamos las palabras de un niño que a
veces pues los pequeños en los que
tienen las palabras más adecuadas
y estaba tan triste lloré toda la semana
no lograba recuperarme
pero pasaron los días las semanas mi
madre nos calmo y nos ayudó lo fuimos
superando juntos
hablamos con amigos hablamos con la
familia al final todos tuvimos que
decirnos que él se había ido y que
estaría con nosotros para siempre y como
escuchábamos este testimonio hay más de
200.000 menores de edad que han perdido
en eeuu un padre una madre un cuidador
primario como por ejemplo abuelos que
también los cuidarán y de nuevos que son
familias sobre todo afroamericanas
familias latinas y las familias también
más empobrecidas que no sólo tienen que
cargar con las consecuencias económicas
también de perder a uno de los
integrantes de la familia sino también
pues al final estos dolores individuales
familiares pero es que también
comunitarios han supuesto cargas
distintas para las distintas poblaciones
de este país triste marc lo que ha
dejado la pandemia pero todavía no hemos
hablado de la situación de áfrica que
sabemos al respecto
más allá de las cifras que sabemos que
bailan un poco más que en otras regiones
y a veces es difícil calcular realmente
el impacto que ha tenido la pandemia en
este caso hay un problema social y es
que el kobe 19 sobre todo se ha llevado
a los hombres no tanto por un tema de
dinámicas sociales de trabajo y de
exposición como también por un tema
médico sabemos que el coi 19 se está
enseñando más en la población masculina
eso que ha dejado detrás pues muchísimas
mujeres viudas que dependían de sus
esposos pero es que también de las
familias de sus esposos pues para
sobrevivir sobre todo en el tema
económico y ahora se encuentran a mucho
más desprotegidas mucho más desamparadas
por culpa de estas dinámicas sociales
alrededor del matrimonio muchos no
tienen derecho a herencia no tienen
derecho a sucesión no tienen formas
económicas de sostenerse entonces pues
vamos a escuchar también para finalizar
un testimonio que llega desde nigeria
donde por ejemplo el 70 por ciento de
las muertes en ese país por covite han
sido precisamente en hombres de
escuchemos
y me dijeron que era mejor que me fuera
con mis hijos porque nadie aquí me iba a
ayudar la familia de mi esposo incluso
me dijo que me volviera a casar de nuevo
pero lo mejor es que deje la casa cuanto
antes por mí por mis hijos y me quedo
sufriré mas jackson you con revolvemos
que estos dolores de la muerte son
universales muchos los compartimos pero
todas las consecuencias sociales que
deja detrás como vemos no se han
repartido de forma igualitaria vacía es
más la desigualdad de nuestro mundo que
lamentablemente vamos a tener que quedar
con esto pues por siempre al parecer
lamentable esperemos que no esperemos
que no gracias mar como siempre por toda
la información de salud nos vemos mañana
con más saludamos a nuestro segundo
invitado el día